davvero pensate che il valore della
nostra vita sia legato al lavoro
spesso associamo così tanto il nostro
lavoro
al valore della vita che non riusciamo a
vedere un dopo
il valore della vita è legato ha molto
altro a qualcosa di più grande
sicuramente
essere parte di qualcosa molto più
importante
ed essere legati a quello che è uno
scopo collaborativo
ci troviamo di fronte a una sfida
importantissima per il nostro pianeta
potrebbe sembrare un'utopia fare finta
di nulla e andare avanti così come se
nulla fosse
invece la vera utopia è portare un
cambiamento
il cambiamento è necessario ed è
imminente
e come possiamo fare a portare un
cambiamento Come possiamo accettare una
sfida così importante che riguarda tutto
il nostro pianeta
il percorso della sostenibilità è un
percorso fondamentale in questo momento
e diventa davvero lo scopo collaborativo
il percorso della sostenibilità può
davvero supportare il nostro ecosistema
oggi se noi riusciamo a pensare
all'ambiente come un alleato non come un
fondo che dobbiamo andare a sfruttare in
maniera indiscriminata
dobbiamo e dobbiamo cercare tutti
insieme di pensare ad una soluzione che
preveda una strategia forte importante a
livello economico a livello ambientale a
livello sociale
come possiamo fare di nuovo
con questa sfida così imminente
forse possiamo pensare a quelli che sono
stati i più grandi innovatori del
passato e l'Italia né fiera perché ne ha
conosciuti davvero tantissimi
i grandi innovatori del passato spesso
cercavano di trovare le soluzioni
Proprio per andare a migliorare la vita
delle persone e come facevano andavano
oltre i limiti
andavano oltre i limiti pensavano fuori
dagli schemi
e cercavano di applicare un innovazione
Forte una forte creatività ed è questo
che forse noi dovremmo fare in questo
momento
liberare la nostra creatività applicare
la creatività innovativa in tutti i
nostri campi e cercare insieme di andare
veramente ad affrontare questa sfida
così importante per salvaguardare il
nostro pianeta
è un nostro dovere è un dovere
importante di tutti noi è un dovere del
presente per il futuro è un dovere per
noi stessi ma anche per tutte le future
generazioni quello di pensare di
salvaguardare il nostro ecosistema
attraverso una strategia condivisa una
condivisa comune strategia
lavoro da tanti anni nel mondo della
moda e del lusso è sempre stato
considerato un settore questo
motivo un settore poco incline a
condividere soluzioni progetti processi
Ma negli ultimi anni questo paradigma
Per fortuna è venuto via via a mancare e
si è evoluto
tante aziende che mai prima si sarebbe
pensato potessero sedere lo stesso
tavolo ora proprio a nome di quella che
è la sostenibilità una responsabilità
sociale forte
un'innovazione responsabile
si stanno sedendo insieme stanno
lavorando insieme stanno cercando di
trovare delle soluzioni di lavorare a
dei progetti a condividere delle idee a
trovare anche dei processi nuovi a
livello tecnologico
e questo diventa fondamentale Dobbiamo
capire davvero che soltanto insieme mano
nella mano le diverse aziende potranno
portare un minore impatto di quello che
è l'impatto che oggigiorno viene
prodotto in uno dei settori che viene
considerato più importante
ed è così che si deve capire che piano
piano ovviamente si portano i
cambiamenti i cambiamenti devono essere
portati avanti con quello che è uno
scopo collaborativo lavorando insieme
non si può più fare la differenza in
maniera individuale
su questo Tanti giovani Tanti giovani
designer tanti Brand consolidati Brand
nuovi startup stanno lavorando per
cercare di trovare un modo positivo per
rispondere a questa sfida globale
Sappiamo benissimo che non siamo in un
mondo ideale ma ci dobbiamo provare e
questo già molto importante
Che cosa significa questo impegno nel
nostro settore significa veramente
lavorare con una creatività liberata che
ci permetta nei diversi settori di
andare a trovare delle soluzioni nuove
non pensare più in base a quelli che
sono gli standard ma pensare di nuovo
fuori dagli schemi andare oltre i limiti
non percorrere sempre la stessa strada
la stessa strada predefinita
spesso quando non conosciamo delle cose
ne abbiamo paura abbiamo timore abbiamo
paura di sbagliare e quindi non le
affrontiamo
ed è questo che è stato fatto per tanti
anni da tante aziende non considerando
quelle che potevano essere le
ripercussioni delle loro decisioni
oggi questo non è più possibile
ed è fondamentale
iniziare a utilizzare la tecnologia per
dare una spinta fortissima a questo
cambiamento la tecnologia però non va
subita La tecnologia va guidata deve
essere guidata con un'innovazione
responsabile
E questa missione questa visione deve
essere una visione condivisa di nuovo io
parlo di scopo
collaborativo perché
perché dobbiamo pensare che tutte le
volte che noi veramente abbiamo una
visione e vogliamo andare ad applicare
una strategia importante non possiamo
pensare che questa strategia sia
vincente se non è condivisa la
condivisione la modalità di lavorare
insieme e di avere una visione comune
porta al risultato E fa sì che davvero
quella visione possa essere implementata
e possa diventare davvero realtà oggi ci
sono tanti processi nuovi tecnologici
che vengono
applicati questo comporta il fatto di
poter produrre in maniera diversa
cercando di ridurre il consumo di acqua
il consumo di energia cercando di
ridurre la produzione di quelli che sono
gli scarti piuttosto che cercare di
ridurre le sostanze tossiche all'interno
dei prodotti stessi
sicuramente l'innovazione va guidata e
sicuramente i prodotti che oggi vengono
offerti sono prodotti sempre più attenti
agli ecosistemi alla biodiversità al
rispetto delle persone
però non è il singolo prodotto non è il
singolo processo questo non può essere
davvero vincente se dietro non c'è una
strategia forte di cambiamento se questa
strategia davvero non venga applicata in
maniera libera liberando la creatività
su tutti i campi facendo sì che funzioni
diverse all'interno delle aziende ruoli
diversi all'interno delle aziende ma
anche settori diversi in quello che è il
mondo del lavoro possono lavorare
insieme per trovare delle soluzioni che
non sono mai state percorse in passato
di nuovo quindi ritorno a quella che è
il nostro incipit di oggi
Qual è veramente il valore del lavoro Se
questo lavoro non viene condiviso con
quelle che sono le persone che ogni
giorno dedicano la loro vita al lavoro
è fondamentale questa condivisione è
fondamentale pensare di portare un
cambiamento lavorando tutti insieme
grazie
[Applauso]